想像一下這個場景。敏感文件已離開
您的組織。
直到一週後才有人意識到這一點。
現在，你只能在
證據不全和
時間緊迫的情況下，努力拼湊出事情的真相。在安全營運中，正是
這些時刻需要
快速回答哪些資料外洩了、誰
接觸了這些資料以及下一步該怎麼做。讓我向
大家介紹一個課程，我們將
學習如何
使用 Microsoft Purview 和
相關調查工具來應對這些現實世界的場景。
您好，歡迎光臨。很高興您
加入我們。我是
微軟技術訓練師 Jean-François Sobiecki。在
本課中，我們將探討學習路徑
三：使用 Microsoft Purview 來緩解威脅
。我們將一起了解
安全營運分析師如何
支援合規和調查
工作流程，從資料遺失
預防警報開始，逐步過渡到內部
風險管理，然後使用
電子發現和審計來調查、
驗證和匯出您
需要的證據。
那麼，就讓我們開始今天的課程。
在這裡，我們為更大的任務奠定了基礎
，即
使用微軟安全營運
平台防禦網路威脅。目標不僅是發現
威脅，還要有
效率地調查威脅。將安全訊號和合
規性證據連結起來，
當資料或
使用者面臨風險時，可以自信地採取行動。
讓我們來看看我們將要涵蓋哪些內容。
我們將首先介紹 Microsoft Purview
合規性解決方案，然後深入
探討如何調查和修復
Microsoft Purview 資料遺失防護
策略所識別出的受損實體。接下來，我們將探討如何
調查
和補救
微軟權限策略辨識出的內部風險威脅
。接下來，我們將轉向
使用 Microsoft
Purview eDiscovery 內容搜尋的調查技術，
然後我們將完成
使用 Microsoft Purview 審計的調查。首先是
審計標準，然後我們將討論
審計溢價。
接下來，我們將介紹 Microsoft
Purview 合規解決方案的功能，該功能
旨在幫助組織保護
敏感資訊、履行監管
義務，並在出現問題時進行調查
。
對於像我們這樣的安全營運分析師來說，
關鍵在於了解這些工具如何
透過
合規層級的證據和控制來補充安全檢測。
若要存取這些合規性功能，
您需要使用
位於 purview.microsoft.com 的 Microsoft Purview 入口網站。
透過這個集中式門戶，您可以
存取資料遺失
預防、內部風險管理、
電子取證和稽核等領域。它們各自
支援
調查和應對生命週期中的不同環節。
讓我們明確一下安全營運
分析師通常如何與合規
和電子取證管理員合作。  其中
一個主要領域是電子發現，
特別是內容搜索，它
支持查找和匯出
可能
需要作為法律案件或
內部案件證據的相關電子資訊。
另一個關鍵領域是審計。 Microsoft
Purview 審核解決方案提供了一種
整合的方式來擷取和審查
使用者和管理員活動，幫助
組織應對安全事件、
支援取證調查和進行
內部調查。
我們還提供資訊保護，
其中資料遺失防護 (DLP) 可協助
組織防止使用者
不當分享敏感
資訊，例如財務資料、
專有資料、信用卡號、
健康記錄或社會安全
號碼。最後，內部風險
管理將各種
訊號關聯起來，以識別潛在的惡意
或無意的內部風險，例如智慧
財產權盜竊、資料
外洩或安全違規，以便團隊
能夠在問題擴大之前發現並控制問題
。
現在我們進入第一個調查
模組，使用 Microsoft Purview DLP
策略來識別受損
實體，然後補救
情況。
關鍵在於將
敏感資料外洩等 DLP 訊號轉化為
清晰的調查路徑和可操作的
後續步驟。
完成本模組後，你應該
可以做到三件事。首先，
描述 Microsoft Purview 中的關鍵資料遺失防護
元件。其次，
直接在
Microsoft Purview 合規中心調查 DLP 警報。
最後，也要調查
M​​icrosoft Defender for Cloud Apps 中的 DLP 警報，這在
查看
雲端應用程式活動和檔案相關
控制項時尤其有用。
透過資料防洩漏策略，您可以識別
敏感資訊並防止
意外分享該資訊。
您還可以
直接在
Excel、PowerPoint
和 Word 的桌面版中監控和保護敏感內容，因此保護不僅限於
網路。另一個重要的好處是
教育不會中斷。 DLP 可以
幫助使用者了解如何在保持
工作流程順暢的同時遵守相關規定。
從調查方面來看，您可以
查看 DLP 警報和報告，其中顯示的
內容與您組織的 DLP
策略相符，從而為您提供可以採取行動的證據
。
要了解這些警報是如何
產生的，了解其中
涉及的核心組件會有所幫助。敏感
資訊類型、敏感度標籤、
資料遺失防護策略本身，
以及在雲端應用場景中，
雲端應用檔案策略的防禦者。
本文將介紹如何
直接在 Microsoft View 中調查 DLP 警報。當
觸發警報時，您可以查看哪些
內容符合策略、警報
發生的位置、
涉及的使用者以及採取了哪些操作
。因此，您可以快速確定
這究竟是意外事故、危險的
模式，還是
需要升級處理的潛在危機。
接下來，我們來看看如何調查
Microsoft Defender XDR 中的 DLP 警報
。一個切實可行的方法是建立
並應用警報過濾器，並將
類別設定為資料遺失防護。
這有助於您快速從
更廣泛的事件佇列切換到與
敏感資料
外洩相關的警報子集。
值得注意的是，Defender
for Cloud Apps 和 Cloud Apps 警報已
合併到 Microsoft Defender
XDR 中。因此，這裡成為了對
雲端應用
相關的資料防洩漏活動以及其他
安全訊號進行分類和關聯的中心場所。
現在，我們從意外資料
外洩轉向了另一個
風險類別——內部風險。
此處的目的是調查
和補救
微軟內部
風險策略識別出的威脅。
無論這種行為是惡意的、
疏忽的，還是僅僅因為在特定情況下風險較高
。
完成本模組後，您將
能夠解釋
Microsoft Purview 中的內部風險管理如何協助
預防、偵測和控制
組織內部風險。您也
可以描述內建的預先定義
策略模板，列出建立內部風險策略
之前必須滿足的先決條件，
並解釋在處理
內部風險管理案例時可以採取的行動類型。  內部風險管理旨在協助您
應對可能來自組織內部的各種風險和
違規行為
。這可能包括故意濫用（例如資料竊取）或無意行為（
例如意外
洩漏或違反政策）。  這裡的
關鍵在於相關性。內部風險管理並非著眼於單一孤立事件，而是將各種
訊號
綜合起來，以突顯
值得調查的模式。
在這裡，我們將詳細介紹 Microsoft 365 用於
識別和解決內部風險管理中的
內部風險活動和合規
問題的工作流程。
這個工作流程的重點在於從
訊號到指標，再到策略
檢測，然後到分類和
調查，
最後到採取適當行動解決風險，同時符合隱私和合
規性
要求。
管理內部風險政策首先要
選擇合適的政策範本。  常見
的範本包括離職員工、資料
竊取、資料洩露，以及
目前處於預覽階段：安全策略
違規、健康記錄濫用和危險的瀏覽器使用。
選擇模板後，您可以
配置策略設置，例如
隱私指標、策略評估的時間範圍以及用於識別風險行為的
智慧檢測，從而在
可見性和隱私性之間取得適當的平衡。
現在我們來談談電子取證。  具體來說，
如何
使用 Microsoft View 搜尋內容。
當調查需要您以符合合規性和法律辯護的方式查找、保存並
可能匯出
Microsoft 365 服務中的內容時，此功能至關重要。  本單元的學習目標很簡單。您將學習
如何指派存取 Microsoft Purview eDiscovery
所需的角色和權限，如何建立和管理用於
執行 eDiscovery 搜尋的金鑰，如何定義搜尋範圍並使用條件、關鍵字和 Copilot 產生的提示建立查詢，以及最後如何使用統計
資料或隨機樣本
執行搜尋
並驗證結果。  讓我們來定義一下什麼是電子取證，以及它與內容搜尋有何不同。  eDiscovery
是 Microsoft Purview 入口網站中的工具，可讓您搜尋內容、設定保留和匯出內容。  只有被分配了正確角色的使用者才能訪問，通常是電子發現經理或電子發現管理員，並且許可會影響您可以使用的功能。 E3 和 E5 包含核心電子發現功能。  您可以使用 Discovery 進行內部
調查，
例如
人力資源案件或涉嫌資料濫用，以及法律和
監管請求、資料主體權利請求、事件回應或違規審查。  電子發現的
核心理念是幫助安全
和合規團隊在調查、法律詢問
或事件回應期間找到、保存和匯出內容
。  此外，使用電子取證不僅僅是將其作為簡單的搜尋功能也很重要。  雖然內容搜尋可以快速檢索數據，但它無法提供與電子發現相同的可審計性和存取控制。
另一方面，電子發現旨在實現與正式案件相關的、
基於角色權限的安全、可審計的搜尋。  在許可方面，核心電子發現功能在 E5 中可用，而高級電子發現功能（通常稱為高級版）增加了諸如
保管人保留
、法律保留通知和內置審查集等功能。即使您不使用高級套餐，了解其中的差異也能幫助您評估您的環境可以支援哪些功能。  理解這一點的一個有效方法是設想一個
真實的調查案例，
例如網路
釣魚攻擊或內部洩密，你需要創建一個案例，運行搜索，並將結果導出以供
審查。  在
使用電子發現存取權限之前，必須明確
分配權限，
以確保調查的安全性和可審計性。所需的角色通常是能夠建立和管理案件、搜尋和匯出的電子取證經理，以及擁有所有經理權限
以及管理角色分配和
控制設定的電子取證管理員。  要指派這些角色，您需要前往 Microsoft 管理門戶，然後導覽至設定、角色
和範圍以及角色群組，並將使用者新增至對應的角色群組。  若要
確認存取權限，您可以在入口網站中進入電子發現功能。  如果使用者擁有正確的角色和許可證，則應顯示建立案例
頁面。  一個關鍵的操作要點是，訪問權限是有意識地進行限制的，即使
有人擁有電子取證工具，他們也只能看到自己參與的案件，這支持最小權限訪問，並將不相關的調查分開。這也有助於在實際
操作中排除常見故障。
如果有人
看不到任何內容，通常是因為他們
缺少角色
分配或案例成員資格。  在 Microsoft Purview 電子發現系統中，每次搜尋都會建立一個 eCase。  此案例可
作為安全、可審計的工作空間，用於
管理調查工作。  這項要求很重要，
因為它能強制執行存取控制，保持一致的調查結構，並確保每一次操作（搜尋、存取、匯出）都記錄
在案件的上下文中。只有
案件成員才能存取案件，即使他們受電子取證規則約束；當其他人創建案件時，他們會自動被添加為成員。
若要建立
搜索，請前往電子取證，開啟案例，然後
選擇
建立搜尋。  您只需提供案例名稱和搜尋名稱，Purview 即可一步建立案例和搜尋。  這種以案例為基礎的結構使得電子取證在法律上站得住腳。它提供了一個容器，您可以在其中進行調查
，盡職調查
和資料完整性可以證明，以備結果需要接受審查時使用。  現在，讓我們一起來看看如何進行搜尋
。其目的是在 Microsoft 365 服務中尋找與安全事件、監管要求或內部調查相關的內容。  首先定義條件，為
搜尋命名，使用關鍵字或條件（例如日期、寄件者或內容類型）設定篩選器。然後，選擇資料來源。使用者、群組、站點，甚至更廣泛的租戶範圍來源，取決於您是想縮小範圍還是擴大範圍。  接下來，你需要建立查詢邏輯。如果您喜歡引導式體驗，可以使用條件建構
器；如果
您需要更進階的篩選，可以編寫 KQL；或者，如果可能，可以嘗試使用 Copilot 或在預覽中按檔案搜尋來產生或加速
搜尋邏輯。  搜尋運行後，您可以查看設定、使用統計資料查看匹配項的數量，
或查看樣本以驗證相關性，然後再匯出。  然後根據需要進行改進和重新運行。一個切實可行的最佳實踐是避免一開始就設定過寬的範圍，因為這會導致審查工作量過大。  相反，應該從小規模
開始，驗證其有效性，然後只有當證據表明需要擴大規模時才進行擴展。  得到正確結果後，下一步就是將它們連同元資料一起匯出。  對於調查文件、
法律審查
或外部
移交，您可以透過在搜尋標籤中選擇已完成的
搜索，然後選擇要匯出的內容（例如已索引項目、部分
索引項目或兩者都匯出）來開始匯出。  然後，您可以設定工作負載選項，例如 OneDrive、SharePoint、Exchange、Teams。
例如，是否包含版本
歷史記錄、包含執行緒
訊息或雲端附件。您可以選擇輸出格式。您希望使用 PST 還是 MSG 文件，並保留
原有的
資料夾結構和易於理解的命名方式？  匯出運行時，您可以在流程管理器中追蹤狀態和詳細資訊。準備
好後，請前往匯出選項
卡，查看匯出概覽，然後下載軟體包以及報告
。這些步驟
對於監管鏈至關重要。匯出包可以包含原始格式和元數據，並且通常以安全包的形式交付，其中包含清單和日誌。雜湊值和導出標識符有助於證明資料的完整性，表明資料未被修改，而安全、有時限的下載連結有助於在傳輸過程中保護導出資料。  現在
，我們進入 Microsoft
視圖審核，它旨在了解 Microsoft 365 中的各項活動。誰在何時何地做了什麼。
審計資料成為事件回應、合規性驗證和深入調查的關鍵
證據，在這些情況下，您
需要可靠的
活動追蹤。  在本模組中，您將學習如何識別 Microsoft Purview Audit Standard 和 Audit Premium 之間的
區別，配置 Microsoft Purview Audit 以實現最佳日誌管理，並執行審核以評估合規性和安全措施。  您還將學習如何使用
審計進階版和 PowerShell 中提供的進階工具分析異常存取模式，以及策略資料管理
如何支援監管合規性。  Microsoft 預覽版審核功能透過擷取使用者
和管理員活動，協助組織了解 Microsoft 365 的使用情況。這種可見性有助於安全調查、合規性要求
和營運透明度。  審計
標準預設為
啟用，提供 180 天的
日誌保留期，可透過入口網站、PowerShell 和 API 存取。  並支援以 CSV 格式匯出結果。  審計高級版透過自訂保留策略、核心服務的預設 1 年保留期、對活動模式的智慧洞察
以及用於高級
整合的更高
API 頻寬
來擴展這些功能。  這些選項共同為組織提供了滿足日常需求以及長期調查和監管要求的靈活性。換句話說，審計標準非常適合
用於一般可見性，追蹤登入、文件修改或共享事件等基本活動
。
另一方面，審計增值服務可以提供更深入的取證，用於更
長期或更高風險的
調查，包括需要了解敏感資訊是否真的被存取的情況
。還需要記住
，高級功能取決於許可，
例如 Microsoft 365 E5 或 E5 合規
性或等效的附加元件。  因此，只有當您的環境具備這些功能時，您才能看到這些功能。
現在，我們來看看配置和管理。如果審核功能尚未啟用，您可以透過 Purview 入口網站或在 PowerShell 中
執行 Set-AdminAuditLogConfig cmdlet 來啟用它。  您還需要核實許可證資訊。審計標準包含在 Microsoft 365 E3 和 E5 以及 F1 和 F3 中，也包含在 Office 365 E1、E3 和 E5 中。  審計高級版需要 Microsoft 365 E5、E5 合規性或相關
附加元件。
最後，角色決定了誰可以處理稽核日誌。
審計讀取器
可以搜尋和匯出日誌，而審計管理器不僅可以搜尋和
匯出日誌，還可以管理審計設定
。  即使某人是全域管理員，
他們仍然需要在 Purview 中擁有正確的角色分配才能存取日誌。良好的調查習慣是儘早確認稽核功能是否已啟用，因為如果日誌記錄未開啟，可能無法追蹤活動軌跡。
審計標準提供了搜尋、管理和分析 Microsoft 365 中活動所需的工具，
協助組織應對事件並滿足合規性要求。您
可以使用 Microsoft 視圖入口網站或 search-unified audit log 指令搜尋審核
日誌。搜尋時，您可以按活動類型、使用者、文件或網站、日期範圍、工作負載進行篩選，並且
可以透過 API 匯出結果或
存取日誌以自動化。
透過該命令，
您可以監控作業進度、深入查看詳細結果，
並按操作、使用者、IP 位址、
記錄類型或專案詳細資訊進行篩選
。  需要考慮的一個實際限制是標準出口規模。匯出功能有限，因此該層級最適合進行針對性查詢，而不是大規模分析。  從概念上講，審計日誌可以幫助你講述事件經過，而你發現的內容取決於你詢問的內容。因此，選擇與你預期看到的
活動相符的篩選條件非常重要。
另一方面，審計高級版可以更深入了解使用者活動，幫助您調查敏感存取
、偵測可疑行為
並應對事件。
一個經典的例子
是使用郵件發送存取活動來調查電子郵件存取權限。
這可以顯示哪些訊息被訪問過
、被誰訪問過以及從
哪裡訪問過。  在活動中，綁定存取日誌單一電子郵件視圖，同時同步存取
日誌批次下載，例如當郵件匣同步到 Outlook 時。  還有一些實際的考慮因素，例如限制日誌記錄，在每個郵箱每天 1,000 次綁定事件後暫停記錄，並自動過濾
重複條目以減少噪音。  您可以在視圖入口網站中
分析這些事件，或者在需要進階篩選和匯出到 CSV 時使用 PowerShell，這有助於您查看
原始審核日誌中的存取類型和限制詳細資訊。
這正是審計真正發揮法務作用的地方，它可以幫助回答諸如離職員工是否查看過敏感資訊之類的問題，而不僅僅是是否下載過某些內容
。  將稽核日誌匯出為 CSV 檔案有助於進行更深入的
分析，並有助於
滿足合規性要求。流程首先在 Microsoft 權限
入口網站中執行搜索，然後選擇 Excel 以
CSV 檔案格式下載最多 50,000 條審計記錄。  若要進行分析，您可以使用 Excel 中的資料開啟 CSV 文件，然後從文字/CSV 並使用 Power Query 編輯器將
稽核資料列從 JSON 轉換為可讀列。  從那裡，您可以展開您關心的屬性，例如 IP 位址、存取類型、項目
詳細信息，以便您可以專注於相關的內容。  當您需要關聯跨服務的事件或識別異常情況（例如非工作時間的異常存取）時，此功能尤其有用。  審計資料保留是滿足監管和調查要求的重要組成部分。使用審計進階版，您可以獲得自訂保留策略，
控制
審計資料的保留時間
。  預設情況下，進階版為 Exchange、SharePoint、OneDrive 和 Microsoft Entra ID 提供一年的保留期。預設
策略無法更改，但
可以
根據具體需要覆蓋
自訂策略
。  透過自訂保留策略，您可以建立多達 50 個策略範圍，針對特定使用者、記錄類型或活動，並將資料保留時間從 7 天到 10 年不等。不過，要保留 10 年，需要額外購買許可證。  一個重要的操作細節是，資料
保留期限是在
記錄資料時確定的。因此，這些
變更僅適用於未來產生的新資料。
從風險角度來看，更長的保留期可以增強對緩慢發展的事件的抵禦能力，並有助於受監管的行業，因為調查或審計可能會追溯到數年前。  讓我們回顧一下本模組所涵蓋的內容。  我們研究了 Microsoft Purview 審核標準版和 Microsoft Purview 審核高級版之間的區別，如何使用 Microsoft Purview 審核搜尋已審核的活動，
以及如何在實務中實
作審核
日誌搜尋。
我們也討論了審計日誌搜尋如何幫助調查常見的支援問題，以及審計高級版如何利用審計
標準版的功能進行更深入的調查。  最後，我們介紹如何建立稽核日誌預防策略，以及稽核
如何支援對被盜用使用者帳戶進行取證調查。  現在，讓我們透過這個簡短的示範來看看 Microsoft Purview 的實際應用。  讓
我們來學習如何在 Purview 中啟動審計。我們目前使用的是 Microsoft Defender，但讓我們從這裡存取 Purview。從 Defender 欄向下移動，查看更多資源。  這使我們
能夠連結到其他入口網站，包括
Microsoft Purview 入口網站。我們打開它。  現在，當我們打開它時，它會告訴我們需要使用舊的合規入口網站。讓我們手動
切換到新入口網站。  現在我們來到了微軟Purview入口網站。我們在這裡唯一要做的就是探索如何開始審計和基本搜尋。我們來談談解決方案和審計。
這是我們的按鈕，開始記錄使用者和管理員活動
。  我們會開始的。開始審計需要一兩分鐘時間，從那時起，在我們收集到足夠的資訊後，我們就可以開始查詢並根據
需要建立案例。  最後，我們快速回顧一下學習路徑
。我們已經介紹了微軟
Purview 如何提供合規性解決方案來降低威脅。我們討論了內容搜尋作為 Microsoft Purview eDiscovery 的關鍵功能，並研究了 Microsoft Purview 審核
解決方案，包括審核標準版和審核高級版
。您
可以看到，審計標準預設為啟用，並提供了記錄審計活動答案的功能，而審計高級版則
在此基礎上，
提供了更高級的審計功能，以滿足更深入的調查和更長期的需求。  我們的會議到此結束。繼續學習之旅的方式有很多種。
我們鼓勵您觀看本課程中的
其他
視頻，或在
Microsoft Learn (aka.ms/learn) 上搜尋您下一個感興趣的主題。